parents advice to their kids about
healthy eating and weight could backfire
with harmful effects psychologist Lisa
d'amour discusses this in a new article
for the New York Times website she
writes quote parents worry that comments
on their children's eating habits will
be received as judgments about body
weight or character lisa is a CBS News
contributor and is here with the best
way to start the conversation good
morning morning this is such an
important topic because you want to be
able to address your kids eating habits
but at the same time you don't want it
insult them or say something wrong about
their body image what's the best way to
approach it you know I think this can be
more neutral than we think it can and
there's a few different ways to keep it
neutral one is we can just focus on the
biological realities human bodies need a
certain amount of nutrition to survive
and we can only eat so much in a day so
what we eat has to provide that
nutrition so if you eat a lot of cookies
that will give you energy but it doesn't
give you vitamins and minerals and all
of the things you need to go on another
way we can approach it is from the
context of self-care that how we eat is
how we look after ourselves and we need
to eat foods that sustain us and we need
to not eat too much of what's hard on
our bodies and then the last way and
this is a really interesting one is to
talk about the broader impact of our
food choices that we can eat an apple
which is relatively kind to the
environment or we can eat a highly
processed apple flavored stack from a
factory and a lot of packaging and
that's harder on the environment and
this last one is interesting because
when you eat in a way that you feel is
good for the environment you get this
immediate gratification and it's
gratification that usually has us
choosing the less healthy choice you and
this makes it easier to make a healthier
choice sounds so civilized honestly when
you're sitting there and you see a child
that's out of control of a friend of
mine that is a very overweight son yeah
and I saw her the other day asked him if
he wanted another piece of cake I had to
stop myself because it's not my child
right I just stopped myself from saying
is that really the best thing to do so
you're saying don't make any judgments
and just say talk about health well I
think what we can say is are you still
hungry right and have you had nothing
but cake today or do you also need
something that's going to give you
nutrition so it's still neutral go back
to the question of self-esteem and body
decides yep
so these of course get quickly tangled
up together because we have a lot of
problems around self-esteem we see body
satisfaction dropped very precipitously
especially in adolescent girls so it
does matter how we talk about food and
it does matter how we talk about
appearance and weight and the general
wisdom around talking with children is
to avoid conversations about dieting to
avoid comments on weight and to put our
emphasis on eating healthy and being
active and children are modeling their
parents behaviors usually children eat
what parents see yep consistently we see
houston we have a problem do what I say
know what I do know I didn't do that
well I admit I didn't do that well you
actually you say actually bringing in
the idea of the social justice or what
it means to do with the environment yeah
it actually be really motivating explain
that how you so for teenagers in
particular they do really well with
messaging that involves sort of sticking
up for the little guy and so there's
this great research that shows that when
you highlight two teenagers look highly
processed foods they're heavily marketed
you know there's some manipulation in
there or you know a factory does a lot
of you know harm to the environment
teenagers can actually really change
behavior with that kind of information
can we tell you about the presidential
election norton made an interesting
observation yesterday that she hadn't
heard from a nine-year-old boy who said
you know i now know about the P word and
the B word you know you're looking at
the news where they're giving
disclaimers about this not might not be
suitable for children we're talking
about the presidency of the United
States yeah
so we how do we have these conversations
with young children about what those
words mean well I think there's two ways
we can go at this you know one is to
talk about the impact of language and
then also talking about what words mean
right these are two different things so
we can say look language can be used for
harm and we should be we're having these
conversations at home anyway
right and the kids are calling each
other names anyway so we can extend that
conversation happening but then there
you know there are names that they may
be learning words that they haven't
heard before yes and you know if your
kid says what does this mean you know I
think the first question back is always
what do you think it means
you know usually they have an idea and
you want to find out what they think
before you start with your idea and then
I think you can say you know those are
words that are meant to cause
and that's a word that describes a part
of a person's body and it's meant to
cause harm well said
you're welcome